wer garantiert mich dass ich existiere
dass ich in diesem moment hier bin dass
ich redet dass ich das was ich sehe
einfach authentisch und und realist oder
wenn ich mit jemandem reden dann dann
merke ich habe die wahrnehmung ich bin
hier und ich rede mit dieser person und
ich kann was von dieser person lernen
und die person kann was von mir lernen
und vor allem ich merke dass sich
existiere in dem moment wo ich die
menschen die ich liebe verlieren
zum beispiel wenn ich eine freundin
nicht mehr da habe wenn ich eine eine
wichtige person in meinem leben
plötzlich fällt in dem moment merke ich
das sicherlich sehr weil die person
nicht mehr existiert und dann weiß ich
ich bin da ich bin geblieben und ich
muss kämpfen
allein die nicht mehr da ist dann sind
die gedanken und die wahrnehmung ist
doch die christa existiert und die
christa muss weitergehen